You cite a tired brain,
foggy thinking as the reason to stop
answering questions or giving a talk.
How do you combat this well
working or writing daily?
Um,
well,
I eat a big breakfast
relatively soon on waking.
That really helps.
If any of you out there are anxious
and many of you no doubt are,
there'll be a large number of you who
are anxious and don't eat breakfast and
there'll be a whole bunch
of you out there who think,
well,
I don't eat breakfast.
It isn't necessary.
It's like,
that's wrong.
It's necessary.
You fasted all night.
If you load yourself cognitively
or physiologically in the morning,
your brain stressed will produce,
um,
will encourage your
body to produce insulin.
It will take all the blood sugar out of
your blood and then you're done for the
day and then you'll be anxious.
And another lot of the rest of you too,
you'll find if you're anxious,
try this.
It's really,
really interesting.
Um,
experiment.
The next time you're anxious,
go eat something.
Eat like,
eat some protein and fat would be best.
You could have cheese and crackers.
I'm not a big fan of carbohydrates,
but whatever.
Eat whatever you're willing to eat,
but make it solid.
Don't eat a peanut butter or don't eat
a chocolate bar or something sweet.
Eat something substantial,
a piece of meat,
a piece of cheese,
some peanut butter,
something like that,
and then wait 10 minutes and see if
you're less anxious and tried out for like
two weeks.
Every time you get anxious,
eat something because then you
can find out if you're anxious,
if your anxiety is linked to low blood
sugar and it's very likely that it is,
especially if you also get irritable
and foggy in your thinking and so,
and the best way to treat that
as far as I've been able to tell,
and there's a decent literature on this,
is to make sure that you eat a
big breakfast and you might say,
well,
I'm not hungry in the morning.
It's like,
who the hell cares if you're hungry?
I didn't say enjoy your breakfast.
I said,
eat it.
That's not the same thing.
You know there's lots of things that
you need to do that you don't enjoy to
begin with.
You'll get hungry in six months
and then you'll start to enjoy it.
So that's a massive difference.
I take small naps quite frequently.
If I'm wiped out,
you know,
I'll go have a nap for 10 minutes or 15
minutes and then that helps quite a lot.
Um,
I try to wake up fairly regular,
a lot on a fairly regular schedule.
That's another thing I would really
recommend for people whose lives are in
disarray and who are anxious.
Try to fix your wake time,
sleep going when you sleep.
That's not so important.
So you can still,
you know,
stay up late and have fun and all that.
But getting up in the
morning is really helpful.
So,
um,
you know,
and you,
you also have to figure out
how much you can work or write.
I can't write for more than about Max.
My sustainable maximum for
writing is three hours a day.
And if I push it past that,
then especially if I'm editing,
I,
I make mistakes when I'm editing.
So that's counterproductive and
I can't sustain it across time.
And so I don't really think you can do
more than about three hours of extremely
intense intellectual work a day.
Although if you have a nap,
you can stretch that.
But I think at least I up
paying for it across time.
So nap,
make sure you eat,
um,
and make sure you eat protein and
fat and not carbohydrates because
carbohydrates are basically poisonous.
Um,
that's about,
that's about and make sure
that you get enough sleep.
So that's,
that's how I combat it and try
to make myself hyper efficient,
which is also a really
interesting thing to try.
You know,
I was talking to my agents at CAA,
creative artists agency in La
and I just hired a publicist to,
to help me manage media in
a more intelligent manner.
And we're trying to think about
our overarching philosophy.
You know when I first proposed to the
CA guys that are overarching philosophy
would be something like,
cause you need an overarching philosophy
under which you nest all your specific
actions.
It was something like to educate as
many people as possible in the shortest
period of time,
which seems like a really good goal.
Like,
why the hell not do that?
But then we broadened out
a little bit this week,
which was to try to do
as much good possible as
efficiently as possible and that
efficiency thing is really fun.
If you guys who are listening
are out for a challenge,
like one of the things that you can,
I think this heightens the meaning in
your life is to try to do difficult
things,
right?
Aim High,
don't name so damn high you can't manage
it and make sure you break down your
aims into reasonably attainable sub goals,
but you want to aim high and then you
want to see how hyper efficient you can
get.
That's a great thing to do in
your early twenties is to see,
okay,
like discipline yourself.
You think,
okay,
how much work can I do if I load
myself right to the maximum?
How far do I,
how far can I work?
How hard can I work
until I exhaust myself?
And then you back off obviously because
the optimal amount of working productive
engagement,
let's say,
is that which is
sustainable across decades.
So you have to,
you have to learn that,
but you don't learn that
without stretching yourself
to your limits to begin
with.
And you know,
if your life isn't everything it could be,
and if you're suffering from
an excess of meaninglessness,
well it means you're not oriented in
the world of chaos and order properly.
It's like you could learn
to discipline yourself,
look,
figure out what,
figure out what it is that you need to
do and that you want to do and then see
how efficient you can get.
Because one of the things that's quite
fun is to figure out if you have a task,
I always tell my graduate students this,
if they're doing an experiment too,
if you have a task that you have to do,
it's really interesting
to spend a few minutes,
sometimes hours,
depending on how long the task is.
See if you can figure
out how to do it from,
from five to 10 times faster.
It means you'll have to rearrange
the way you think about it,
but you can often do it and that's
how extremely productive people get.
So hyper efficient,
you know,
sometimes it means you have to delegate.
It means sometimes it means you
have to bring other people aboard.
That's delegation as well,
I suppose.
Um,
but there's a lot of preconceptions that
you hold about who you are and who the
world is that you could dispense with
that would make you a way more efficient
actor in the world.
And so,
yeah.
All right.
So that's that.